Speaker 1: We have a voicemail
number. That number is 2192 David P.
Here's a teacher who called a teacher
about the idea of arming teachers in school.
Speaker 4: Hey, David. Tim here, a teacher from
Pennsylvania. Look, there is no political will to.
Speaker 3: Act on gun legislation, so instead,
I suggest we just start treating
schools like an airport. Here you go.
Dogs. High security teams with SWAT.
Speaker 4: Gear and long guns.
Guys on the roof. Treat it like an airport.
They got a man. They put their backpack
through a scanner. There's metal doors.
Speaker 3: There's security teams.
Speaker 4: The whole thing. There is no
political will to act on gun legislation.
Speaker 3: Let's just treat schools like a
prison and just own that. This is the society
that we live in.
Speaker 4: A disgusting,
depraved society. Keep up the great work.
Speaker 3: Work, David. Talk to you soon.
Speaker 1: Now, the circumstances here in the
United States are so sick that I can't tell
whether this teacher is saying this tongue in
cheek, like saying, hey, listen, if we can't
deal with guns, I guess we just turn the schools
into prison like circumstances. And I don't know
if he's saying it as in like obviously that's not
a good idea or if he's genuinely saying we've got
to do that. He, I, I, the circumstances are so
depraved that I don't know if he's being sarcastic
or if he's just giving up and saying, we have no
other choice. That's exactly what we have to do.
Wow, what a situation. We have a great bonus show
for you today. We're going to continue talking
about a number of different things. We're going
to talk about a Juneteenth controversy. We're
going to talk about a settlement involving
Twitter and user data on the bonus show.
It's been a big shooting heavy show. So we're
going to take a break from the shooting stuff
on the bonus show. But unfortunately, I have
way more to talk about tomorrow, including
the forthcoming NRA convention so you can sign
up for the bonus show. It joined Pacman dot com
and then otherwise we'll be back
tomorrow. And then we've got multiple
streams coming up into the weekend, the
NRA convention, the Trump rally in Wyoming,
which I'm sure will be completely unhinged.
So much content over the next few days.